el mayor recorte de la oferta petrolera
desde mayo 2020 en su primera reunión
cara a cara desde la pandemia de Kobe 19
la Organización de Países exportadores
de petróleo y sus aliados anunciaron que
van a reducir su bombeo de petróleo
mundial en dos millones de barriles
diarios a partir de noviembre un 2% de
la demanda global según la organización
la decisión Busca contener la caída de
los precios del petróleo y brindar
seguridad al mercado energético no
estamos poniendo en peligro los mercados
energéticos estamos brindando seguridad
y estabilidad a los mercados energéticos
los representantes de la organización
fueron cuestionados y algunos señalan
que la decisión sería una especie de
cooperación con Rusia una acusación que
rechazaron
Muéstrame Dónde está el acto de
beligerancia
el anuncio de este recorte ha tenido
consecuencias inmediatas impulsando el
alza de los precios del barril de
petróleo el brent alcanzó un máximo de
93,96 dólares nivel que no conseguía
desde el 15 de septiembre por su parte
Estados Unidos criticó la decisión
catalogando la de cortoplacista y
partidista
mire está claro que la OPEP más se
alinea con Rusia con el anuncio de hoy y
así al tomar esta decisión va a tener un
efecto en los países de ingresos
económicos bajos y medios
el anuncio sea en un contexto complejo
para la energía a nivel mundial la
invasión rusa de Ucrania disparó los
precios a máximos de casi una década
un panorama al que se le suma la
prohibición europea sobre la mayor parte
del petróleo Ruso y se enmarca como una
negativa ante los pedidos occidentales
de que la OPEP produzca más combustible